let's bring in ray Ratto from Comcast
Sports Net Bay Area he was there last
night as the Giants went down in flames
that that bullpen came back to haunt you
ray how would you describe what happened
there at the end uh like a bunch of
other games watching a watching a star
collapse to the size of a diamond
because you get they've imploded bigger
times than this but never on that level
of stage and with that many pictures I
mean it literally was a conga line you
know that was lookin fer o from the
bullpen to the mound and it just it got
better and better and better mean if you
like a train wreck and it was it was it
got to be almost weirdly hilarious
because you know they'd been it had
bullpen problems all year but this was
the one where basically they emptied out
everything they had and couldn't figure
anything out I mean it's you know it
took 24 minutes 24 pitches six guys and
they blew it three run late it was I
mean you can't make stuff up like that
unless you drink more than most of us do
and you don't get a chance to see
Bumgardner again but I felt like the
Cubs did not one of all the teams they
did not want to face this team in in the
playoffs their ability to win games but
you're right the bullpen came back and
and haunted them but did you get any
sense of what this cub team is really
all about after watching this series
well I think I think I sort of knew
because I mean I mean I watch a lot of
baseball but you see it up close and i
will say this if you haven't seen Javier
Baez in person you're not getting the
whole picture you you literally have to
be at the ballpark watching how quick
his hands are and how smart a player he
is because it just emanates off him I
mean you can't you can't get the full
sense on TV because everything is sort
of slightly distorted and sped up but
when you see it in real time with your
eyes you go he's doing things that can't
be done and there should be an
investigator
are the Cubs the last great sports story
um no I think there were reprise of the
Red Sox before they became you know you
know the Mega Money team uh it's sort of
it's sort of a retelling of that only
with you know additional years tacked on
but you know III think you know as the
last great sport story yeah we will find
another one because we always do uh it I
think it would be more interesting if
they had one before the Red Sox did
because then you know there wouldn't be
a template that we could compare them to
but the Red Sox are that template and so
in that way there's a little bit of you
know well we've seen this for a national
audience in Chicago yeah it's it's it's
the needles way in the red but
everywhere else i think it's it's more
of a yeah we saw that and I've you know
it's sort of like how people in anyone
feel about leicester city it's just you
take a team that's never been anything
and then all of a sudden you know give
them all the lotteries at once and you
get that sense but it no I mean it's
still gonna be a tremendous story it's
just we've seen it before in a different
way in a different town but locally yeah
it's the only thing going Niners decided
to start calling Kaepernick Sunday
against Buffalo why is he starting now
um well I I think Chip Kelly has seen
more than enough and I don't know that
he can sort of you know internally
defend the decision to keep truck
trotting Gabbard out there knowing full
well that Kaepernick is not a fix
because their problems are far more
varied than that but you know you're
you're sort of in a situation what can I
fix I can't get a whole new roster my
defense has lost its best player um what
can I do and I think this is this is
what this feels like more than anything
else it's you know Gabbard has struggled
but you struggle because they
simply no wide receiver is one running
back that every every defense in the
league just sort of purple down on so I
think it's just a matter of you know
well this is the next thing we gotta try
and if this doesn't work well then you
know we're screwed but you know I think
if you waited a whole lot longer then
you've thrown the season away and
putting Kaepernick in is a complete
waste and because Kelly has only been
there for five games and less than a
year I think he wants to be able to try
everything he can try while there's
still hope that they can salvage
something out of this I mean if you wait
till week nine and they're one and eight
then it doesn't really matter your
quarterback is so I think that's why the
weird thing about this of course being
that the the rumors that the 49ers and
Kaepernick's people were talking about
restructuring this contract so that they
would feel more comfortable about
playing him I mean that that's the
disturbing part because that ones are
putting contract they had a football and
that's really not a message you want to
send toward already angry fan base yeah
and that's what I'd heard all along that
there was a holdup here because did
Kaepernick all of a sudden get healthier
because that was the that was the label
that was the story way he's not healthy
enough and then Gabbar nak Gabbert
played so bad that you eventually had to
get around to it but then there was also
this contract if he got hurt and then
maybe he's playing for another job and
be a free agent but have we it is he
less of a lightning rod in the San
Francisco area now as it cooled off a
little bit with the protest
demonstrations yeah be coming and I
don't want to say it's a movement
because you know I don't know that
enough athletes have taken up the cause
but I mean last night in Sacramento the
anthem singer takes an e at the end of
the song so you know I think it's still
touchstone for some people but for the
most part the 49ers and their poor
results have have trumped social
conscience again because they've been
basically unwatchable and I would argue
that they right now are probably the
worst team in the league fire margin I
mean if that is the
as the Bears might be sad if the Jaguars
might be I think right now the Warriors
ID as a 49ers are distinct standard in
the NFL and then you gotta Harbaugh roll
in at Michigan does that strike anybody
as what could have been had he stayed
there could he have possibly stayed
there did the wrong guy leave well given
the fact the choices between him and the
owner there was never a question of the
wrong guy leaving because if you wanted
to make it a right guy wrong guy well
yeah Jim Harbaugh doesn't have the money
to own the team so it was a from the
moment they first got they started
crossing shield you know you knew
Harbaugh was going to lose because you
know he doesn't have a billion dollars
yeah the odds against him winning that
one are basically non-existent so I I
don't know that they're in a I think
people still say well this is when this
team stopped being about football and it
started being about the comfort of the
executive suite and that's gonna linger
uh and it really almost doesn't matter
you know whether Harbaugh gets to play
nothing but Rutgers till the day he
retires but that's always gonna stick in
people's cause here because up until the
time of the new stadium was built the
49ers business was the 49ers they were
playing in Candlestick Park you weren't
making extra money from everything
around it um it was a football operation
pure and simple now it's a now it's a
business of which football is part of it
and you can't sell that to the fan base
and they look at Harbaugh as you know
sort of a a last-gasp before the culture
change I don't think he could have I
don't think he could have saved this
because it's just you know I mean
they've been unlucky that some good
players all retired at the same time and
you saw you know some of that you know
his last year there when they went eight
Nate they were they were not fun to
watch either but I think you know the
fans have spoken they decided who the
enemy is here and it's the people who
stay not the guy who left the way thanks
for getting up early we appreciate it
thanks for stirring it up as well well
give it time that'll blow over
thank you Ray that's ray ratto from
Comcast Sports Net Bay Area the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience